[Music]
marcus is with us marcus is in orlando
florida hey marcus welcome to the ramsey
show
uh hi david john how you guys doing
great man how can we help
uh so i just graduated from college in
december and i'm taking a new job in
february congratulations what's your
degree in
uh civil engineering oh excellent what's
that
what's a new job paying
80 000 a year okay marcus get to work we
got a lot of stuff that needs to be
civilly engineered my man
you're gonna be working for a long time
brother get to work get to fixing it
yep i hear you um what's your question
man what's up
the
job i'm taking is a few hours away from
my parents house um in orlando so um i'm
gonna have to buy a car here
and getting a lot of different advice i
guess from family members and friends on
whether to go new or used and like
looking at new prices versus use prices
i'm not seeing like a huge difference i
guess when we're looking so i was
wondering if you could offer any advice
on where to go for that uh you buy used
and
because even a used car that's say like
15 to 20 thousand
dollars right that'd have to take a loan
out on either no you're not taking out a
loan on anything you gain money
um yeah it's
i have about
let's say like 9 000 in savings and then
um like a decent sized investment
account how much is in your investment
account
about 70 000 is that in a retirement
account
um no it's in a taxable okay pay cash
for your car son buy a car dude
you don't go into debt you got 70 000
so it's cool if i'd sell investments to
buy a car you're dead come right before
you take out a car payment because let
me tell you what the difference is right
let's say you owned a 15 000 car that
was paid for
would you go borrow money on it to put
money in investments
only if you're stupid
yeah i guess you're right and it's the
same thing it's still a balance sheet
issue okay it's the same exact thing i
just did it backwards i reverse
engineered your question so you're
definitely paying cash for a car and you
buy a used one here's the thing
cars
are awesome i love cars i'm a car guy
i'm a gear guy i just love loud mufflers
i'm a redneck
it's awesome man and but but here's the
thing they go down in value it's the
largest thing we all buy
that goes down in value the biggest
mistake brand new college graduates make
is they go buy a brand new car to say
thank you to themselves for graduating
and they put a big butt payment on it
all your friends are doing it
and they're all and they're all screwing
up and your parents saw how much money
your new salary is and their mouth
dropped wide open and then they told you
to go buy yourself a brand new car yep
yeah that's pretty accurate and besides
that with all the supply chain stuff and
the shortages the used cars are
ridiculous so you might as well buy a
new one anyway everybody rationalizes
their butt off no
so hey for what hey for what it's worth
to let you know this isn't a theory i
make more than 80 thousand dollars
and i've got more of my retirement
accounts than you do and i just bought a
used car for my wife what'd you pay for
it
what did we pay for it a lot okay a lot
but you bought used that we bought used
wrote a check for it paid cash good call
it good good okay so that's what you do
i if i were in
maybe go back let me go back because i'm
just we're just chopping him up what
what uh uh what's your income going to
be 80 000
yes correct you did say that he's gonna
make 80. yeah okay i missed that all
right so
uh yeah buy a 15 or a 20 000 car and
write a check and pay cash for it
and then build your emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses which
you pretty much have you just need to
reallocate it to that and then start
your investing and you're going to be a
millionaire very very quickly if you
continue to buy very large things that
go down in value and you continue to buy
very large things that go down in value
on payments you will be middle class
you will not build wealth
most middle class people do three or
four stupid things continuously
throughout their lives and they never
break through into wealth
car payments and buying brand new cars
is one of them whole life life insurance
which is the payday lender of the middle
class is another one
okay and you just get hammered by these
industries that are completely taking
you
to to the the thing and i know some of
these people giving you advice mean well
but they really aren't doing that well
with their finances so you don't need to
take their advice if the last engineer
that uh that last engineer the guy you
work with the last thing he did was a
bridge that fell down i don't really
need his consulting on my next project
you know same thing okay broke people
shouldn't be giving you financial advice
but they do we were just talking about
that and something about you knows that
that's why you called yeah you get a lot
of you got a lot of people
jawing at you you're making a great
salary but something about you knows
i
don't want to get out of college and be
free and then immediately sign myself
back up for debt so i'll tell you what
i'm gonna send you a copy of baby steps
millionaires as your graduation present
show you how to be a millionaire
and i have shown more people how to be
millionaires than just about anybody on
the planet right now so you hold on and
i've actually done it by the way so
check it out this is the ramsey show